foreign
[Music]
or you can do a six four five one
across because
six by one
of those the
five five one six four five one seven
four four one
there's another one that's an extension
of the six four five one when you draw a
six four five one instead of throwing a
six if you throw an eight
getting higher you one more rotation of
a five one
so six four five
hell yeah
eight four one five one
you can go eight four four one five five
one
I can't do
it wrong with my hand today
yeah
never mind
[Music]
ful of an extension of the 6451 via the
eight four five one five one if you
throw the ten obviously you can get one
get one five one five one in there
the game
[Music]
okay
my favorite football size tops are the
five three four five three four
playing with a
star through the fountains do a five
five
let's go inside
juggling a four ball down throw two
Crossing five
if you go into a six one
five five six five six one five six one
five
foreign
[Music]
a different
one more time
boom
um
you can do a 6631 which is pretty
basically
[Music]
so those are fun four ball size
Rob wood
spinning a prop Gathering yes recap at
Demento juggling Festival
all right
right on here